you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens welcome to the game spot
co-op stage here at e3 2016 brought to
you by lego star wars the force awakens
i'm jeff cannata and i am joined by
three of my favorite people in the world
Dave do it Danny a dire ashley Esqueda
guys it's III know and we are drowning
in first-person shooters right it's
great look it's a renaissance it's Anna
it is wait I think that's what we need
to talk about it is a renaissance of
first-person shooters and all of them
seem to want to build huge growing
communities have vibrant multiplayer
leagues and all this stuff is there room
for all of these I mean I could list a
dozen first-person shooters that are big
deal let's start with the mint that the
normies the military shooters even this
year the two annualized military
shooters are doing something different
right battlefield one going back to a
world war one it looks ridiculous
everyone who we have had go play it at
the events I've come back saying that's
incredible yeah and and then you also
call it Judy infinite warfare which is a
game that's actually made me interested
in a call of duty game for the first
time ever possibly because it doesn't
look like a call of duty game anymore
look people in space and then rip their
helmets off and make him died like yeah
man it would look so great so many new
and interesting ways to murder people
how far into that trailer at the at the
press conference were you before you
realize it was a call of duty game yeah
yeah reload animations that gave it away
from me yeah like the flick and then the
slime bucket I was like they look
familiar but at the same time it's in
space hello yeah I loved that they chose
to hold the logo until the end and they
basically said let's surprise everybody
yeah well let's let you realize you like
this before you decide you hate hate
exactly right that was such a brilliant
move strategically I mean it got me
excited and honestly I go to be real
guys I would have checked out if they'd
have been like hey it's the new call
judy hey might have been like where's
that Norman Reedus name bring it back
plane again when you come playing you
know we've house it's the same it's
there's a lot of the same but it's like
this actually feels and looks so
different than what I've experienced in
call of duty the last one I played was
like black ops 2 I did yeah what was
dangerous with that game is that
everyone was excited for the ecology for
remaster and nobody really cared about
the new code of duty now they've
actively made them excited for both
which yes there's more reasons to buy
one game so i would i would put
alongside that so we've got we've got
call of duty infinite warfare we've got
battlefield one i would say the next big
pillar one is titanfall 2 yeah tight
tight I played that this morning oh it's
ridiculously fun grappling hooking is
real fun because every game of a
grappling hook in it now I see here the
grappling hook year the grappling hook
at year of the giant crab boss fights
grabs ya boss fights reason and
everybody giant crabs this year again
also it's the year of the the the cover
song that is a pop song but it slides
down tempo yeah yeah but are you guys
are you guys excited for titanfall 2
yeah I mean I think the first game was
was a tremendous first take for respawn
entertainment I mean it's headed by
vincent bella who is half of the you
know duo who basically made call of duty
and I think this their second bite at
the cherry is gonna be a lot better I
you know they're gonna min max on the
Titans a bit more they're gonna be sort
of more individualistic be they were the
ones who started the whole movement
Renaissance a couple years back and then
we have call of duty try and do that and
then we live in a world where like the
first person shooter Digory is over
watch which is a game entirely based on
the ways in which characters move yeah I
think titanfall I mean it's weird right
that is a stacked couple of weeks
they're coming it's coming either side a
battlefield yeah and I'm do do a lot of
first-person shooting to be happening
are you are you excited for titanfall I
mean anytime I can smash somebody with a
robot I'm in so yeah I'll I'm into it my
biggest hope for titanfall 2 is that the
community doesn't just veer off a cliff
after like two months that's what
happened about first-person shooters
right is that you end up with this kind
of this kind of situation where
everyone's playing or nobody's playing
yeah I'd have a battle front like great
like everybody was in for like two weeks
and then every other game on earth came
out pick around that time I was like
fall out everybody just sort of like
sank into an abyss of playing a million
games well I'm excited for excuse me
titanfall 2 because of the single-player
I'm I tend to be terrible at multiplayer
first-person shooters so I enjoy a great
story that I can have a great time in
that universe and it seems like a really
cool universe and it feels like the
lesson they learned is hey we need a
first a single-player story meanwhile so
many other companies are going we don't
need single player let's make an arena
shooter there are so many first-person
arena shooters coming out I mean over
watches is owning the world right now
but we got lawbreakers we got a new
quake name like champions yeah I know I
know you're excited about quake yeah man
like whenever to make a new quake you're
like okay which quake are you making
because you make me quake 1 which is
this weird gothic Nine Inch Nails fever
dream are you making quake 2 which is
actually kind of just the first person
military shooter is set in the future so
maybe not that one are you gonna make
quick three and it what it looks like
they're making is a spin on quake three
I notice I did not mention quake 4
alright let's quit quit for great the
Frog ification mistake yeah it's yeah we
put off by the side here like exactly
wake forest of doom 3 of quake it was
like they're gonna make a shame like a
hero shooter with in quake where the
heroes that I hate use not worried the
champions I don't know the characters
have individual and powers and the
overwatch style or and adil born or and
before doom I would have been worried
but we live in a host AIDS doom 2016
world and what a world it is rice so now
it's like go for it like I trust you
guys again do you get the sense that it
themselves or and Bethesda itself was
surprised at doom like they didn't send
out review copies they were kind of
playing it close to the vest enroll my
god this is doom game and then everybody
loved it and they're like oh yeah yeah
no we love it too its suspect but it's
interesting you mentioned dude after
quake because the dream single player
was amazing I absolutely adore the doom
single player but the multiplayer was
like really lackluster now you know why
yeah it feels like they've like hampered
their own multiplayer or God all the
multiplayer mistakes out of the way to
make quake when I do my player felt like
a bad quake but they didn't make them on
player critical assembly made the
multiplayer did the multiplayer for halo
anniversary i think couple of others and
now you know why they didn't do an arena
shooter because they were working on the
shooter yeah but it's funny how many of
these other arena shooters were
announced like there's that John Romero
one that was on yeah Kickstarter for a
hot second that they'll and and
lawbreakers like the messaging is like
because there's no quake we had to make
this game the game we wanted to play
because we used to play quake is like
well now there's also a quake so I'm
worried that there's not enough room for
all of these we're gonna see we're gonna
see some rise up and some it's just how
it is like people are just gonna take I
mean when not to get shady but it's like
look at battle born in overwatch right
now I think I mean it's like one goes up
one goes down and that's not to say
battleborn could come back and release
some great patch that brings a lot of
new players in but it's just that's how
it is we can only play one game at a
time so far like we have not yet
developed the technology to play two
games at once which listen I'm okay with
that multi task two games but but yeah I
just I mean we are going to see some
winners and losers and it's just you
know it depends on who who brings it you
gotta bring something interesting you
have to bring something fun super
replayable and also it has to be a
community that sticks around I think
that's really important well I think a
lot of the effort to create community
and it makes something that lasts is by
building in competition and east that
eSports is much more everybody now is
saying and you know Microsoft is talking
about doing it on a sort of global level
and there's a lot of these companies
that are infusing build your own
tournaments and all that stuff into the
games I'm a little skeptical of that I
don't know how much an average player
actually wants to participate in a
tournament watch it watching a
tournament watching pro players play I
think is exciting but participating in
Shermans I think that's being
overestimated a bit you guys agree
that's interesting because like I I come
from a background of watching loads of
eSports like I used to watch competitive
counter-strike street daly and then we
kind of went through a period of shooter
games shoehorning any sports like
Rainbow six siege was like hey hey kids
you want to play a sport
no really man it really depends on the
support that the developer gives it was
I think blizzard to do it really well
and it's already a competitive scene for
overwatch but you really need to have
you need to have that competitive
element going in it needs to be tight it
needs to be precise it needs to be
balanced straight away and it needs to
have these passionate fans to instantly
start playing competitively you need
that critical mass you need a lot of
people involved like you know twitches
this massive force right half of
Twitter's traffic is from
league-of-legends from one game
overwatch is massive and loads of people
are playing it but it needs to be
massive like paddleboards problem was
that there was enough people playing it
it has a two thousand good Kurtz evolved
had the same problem writing fallen
massive drop-off so I mean first person
shooters have to be popular for to you
know have that the multiplayer servers
for through people to play but for it to
really resonate there's an eSport you
it's like it it's like a different
magnitude higher than that and i think
you're right i think everyone wants to
buy tada cherry but there's just too
many of those that can only be like two
or three big esports first-person
shooters surely yeah i can see quake
having a big easeful its presence I
think it'll have a big I think all the
big resurgence um because people like
Danny's still love quake so we see all
these years it's interesting though cuz
unreal tournament has been around for
I've been playing the outfit for at
least a year now and they've sort of
done it the opposite way instead of
having like you know Blizzard had the ok
here we go over watch boom it's finally
out to everyone go play it they've been
tricking people into it for so long rye
and trying to build it and it hasn't
really worked and you could save it on
your tournament a quake had like a
similar-sized fan base sure yeah that's
a good point I mean is it too old that's
the case of franchise too old to come
back out of it cuz you newer younger
gamers like we're old we're all like
it's newer younger gamers they want to
play new stuff yes how many overwatch
players of late action quake which is
basically what that game is right oh
yeah not really none of them yeah
exactly or even even tf2 like so far so
young to have never even played tf2 and
the biggest competitive shooter games
right now like counter-strike a lot of
the big players and that have come from
like 1.6 yeah and quake I think it's
going to also have a backing of it's
going to have the nostalgia backing
where all the old players who are
really good like quake is still play
competitively at quakecon they're now
going to move into new quake and it's
going to have like a big thrust into the
East board seat just off the back of
those guys just seems which which there
was people were eight of us a MOBA for a
second yeah it's still cool i think we
are i did I there was a part of me that
was like I can kind of be into that
being a motive beyond that page you know
uh it would have pissed off a lot of
people I'm sure do you um so do you
think in terms of oh my gosh where did
my question go it's gone now I've never
my good i'm gonna try to rethink of it i
was thinking i thought of something
really good and now I camera I'm sure
it'll come back you know what I was
thinking of prey right okay well let's
talk about pray for for one minute
because why is it called pray right
luckily um I'm very excited for what
they showed but does that IP carry I
mean I know we're talking about it now
go strange like yeah the adventures of
Tommy Hawk the Native American in the
bar with the rye toast I circled song
yeah I played all the way through that
game it's girl it's not a good game it
was not a good game it was fine it
wasn't it was like a great 10 minutes at
the beginning but then there's like
eight more hours of that game brandade
like your spirit animal I was again said
though how many like Bethesda 242 for
bringing back first-person shooters yeah
yeah effing Stein doom are both
fantastic if they can do the same with
pray now they've they've got the license
are you allowed to reboot something that
only existed up in one thing I think it
hasn't even been a sequel to it it's not
even like lodges oh I like to fix my
favorite huge cult classic what it's
like we paid for the IP we might as well
slap it on this game that we're making
somebody making us like a reimagined
more turn it's fun it's like oh yeah I
remember that game duh experience i had
with prey is it always used to be one of
those games that were like 3 4 10 pounds
like bargain yeah yeah yeah you're like
I was like still doesn't look with it oh
I like what you say which is a bummer
because what they showed as being this
new prey as amazing i'm on board for
that kind of psychological sci-fi thing
it's just it the logo came up and i was
like sure well it turns off the people
who actually remember playing it and it
means nothing to the people have never
leighton so that was why i was really
confused by that it makes me feel like
we're at this weird place where
nostalgia for stuff that you don't even
you haven't even played is the thing
right you know like like I remember i'm
talking about when you're on my show we
were talking about you know giving money
to a kickstarter for a game that you
don't like but you kind of feel like is
a thing jen move yeah sad mill it's a
weird place to be of just like sort of
phantom nostalgia you know what's
happening i stained was the same thing
was like a lot of people had never
wanted like a traditional 2d Castlevania
game and they're just like people like a
guy like feel like now it's just like
well yeah give him your money i did but
also like you literally never played a
match a castlevania game the way that it
used to be like a symphony of the night
like Jays weird so we're sitting here
talking about the like Renaissance of
the first person shooter where's to a
lot of people it's just hey there look
at all these good first-person shooters
yeah line to it they didn't even know
when there were none it's weird to think
that people playing first-person
shooters now like new players picking
them up have never played a first-person
shooter that has made you pick up health
packs are the pack like people that
hasn't been really bit of things it's
like do but they've start to slowly
bring elements like that and it was
considered an old school yeah but a lot
of the people playing Call of Duty and
Battlefield are like wait I have to pick
up help I don't just get a bloody screen
and hide in a corner how do I know just
hide and heal myself and understands I'm
Wolverine in every game like I never
understood that but yeah it makes sense
you got that was the genius of doom is
is oh hey instead of incentivizing you
to go hide in the corner right since
advise you to jump into the fray so much
more fun okay so we have a ton of
first-person shooters we've talked about
a bunch of them I'm sure we're leaving
out a few notable ones do that I haven't
thought of but particularly if you can
only walk away from this convention with
one which would you pick oh man totally
put you guys on the spot real hard
battlefield one really I have been
itching for a game that does wills or
one and there was a game that came out
not too long ago called Verdun which was
a world war one game and it was it was a
great game it didn't have the backing
that I think it deserved because it's
kind of like an indie thing but now that
like a big studios picked up the world
or one mantle
okay let's see what we can do with this
event now now I'm excited and seeing
people play it see the game play some of
you some of us guys have hands-on I've
been like just harvest them harvesting
them for information I'm super excited
to go that far back in time shooting
down a Zeppelin does look like a lot of
fun yeah anybody else ever I will roll
the dice on Craig champions it is I
don't know what it is but it was a
railgun a rocket launcher so I mean I
like it I'm gonna make up a game and I'm
gonna say titanfall out where you
instead of wearing power armor where
robots and it's an mmofps any alone
Taylor people you don't allowed to make
them games well I just did it's all that
I'm in a chance Paulette's got mods
somebody's already mad please make that
oh yeah I made yet titanfall out that's
the same time no time fall I think of
them of the competitive multiplayer
shooters that won't the one I think that
I will play the most because mechs are
fun I know I don't think we get to add
dishonor to this list but if but this
idea is the one that I'm I most jonesing
for of the first person view but lots of
amazing first person games lots of other
games lots of coverage here on gamespot
so don't tune away we got we got so much
more coming all week long stay tuned